I was once asked to hit nitroglycerin or
sample of nitroglycerin with a hammer
they pulled some out on a brick gave me
the hammer said stroke it gently and I
did and it went off with one hell of a
bang so today I'm going to talk about a
compound with recently we did one on the
Nobel Prize and Alfred Nobel made his
money from dynamite so I thought we'd do
one on dynamite and nitroglycerine here
is the active ingredient the explosive
in dynamite
it comes from glycerol which is a
natural compound you just nitrate it and
you get nitroglycerin which is a kind of
oily heavy substance but it was found
very quickly that it is very explosive
and in fact it's dangerous to make
Alfred Nobel's genius was to absorb it
onto so-called dead earth and what you
would do he found that if you put the
dead earth on a sheet of paper and then
you rolled that paper up like an arctic
roll then it became an ice stick and you
could transport these sticks and because
it was absorbed onto that dead earth it
gave a bit of shock resistance so he
came he tamed it essentially by putting
it into this stick and calling it
dynamite and dynamite would you normally
get in these sort of sausage shaped
sticks it's really very stable you can
throw it on the fire and it'll just burn
and you need to use a detonator which
produces a real shock wave which then
travels down the stick forcing the
explosion to take place
I was once given a set of photographs
which showed how this explosion travels
down the stick in one ten thousandth of
a second it's all over and it really
looks very dramatic if you're clever you
can focus the shock from an explosion
rather like you can focus light with the
lens and then you can do some really
dramatic things so if you look at this
piece of metal here
it's really quite thick and I was shown
what happens when you take hundred grams
that's not really very much not much
more than this bar of chocolate small
bar of chocolate the salt you eat for
lunch if you use that with the shape
charge set it off here you can make a
hole right through it you can see here
my pencil go right through and you can
see here there's the blast marks you can
even still see 30 years on from when
this was done a few traces of the copper
casing of the detonator and on the other
side you can see where the explosion
burst out so that was a great explosive
in it at the onset of the first world
war this was being used a lot in mines
and also in bombs but the problem with
this compound is nitroglycerine it
explodes very quickly so if you are
trying to explode a bomb and destroy a
building say this when it hits the
outside of the building or a media
explode what you really want is to get
slightly inside the wall before you
explode because then you're going to
blow the wall apart much more
effectively so another Nobel Prize
winner Bader invented this compound and
it's the Germans who invented this in
the early 1900s and you'll know it as
TNT so it made famous by cartoons and
Acme TNT is trying nitro toluene so
these are nitro groups here this blue is
nitrogen the red is oxygen and the
clever thing with both nitroglycerin in
TNT is that in order to burn to make
carbon dioxide nitrogen normally when we
set light to things we need oxygen from
the air to enable that to burn these
have enough oxygens in here to make all
these carbons
turn into carbon dioxide that gas
expands that's what makes the the
explosion TNT was found to have a little
initiation period it's probably not
quite as explosive in absolute power
terms as the nitroglycerin but the great
thing about this molecule was that it
would there'll be a tiny delay a
fraction of a second delay before it
exploded upon impact which meant that
the missile could get partway through
the bunker before it exploded and it
created a lot more damage
the mark 25 torpedo tube is severely
damaged when it detonates the carbon
reacts with an hydrogen react with the
oxygen to make water and carbon dioxide
and the nitrogen atoms combine to make
n2 n2 has one of the strongest bonds
between any two atoms and it's a triple
bond between nitrogen and forming this
bond releases a lot of heat so does the
combination of carbon with oxygen and
hydrogen with oxygen so in effect you
get instantaneous burning there are all
gases the gases expand this is a liquid
so it's dense gases want to expand
they're going to be very hot remember so
they're going to want to expand that is
actually the explosion it's that
expansion and generation of gas in a
confined space it wants to be much much
bigger I work here in Nottingham and
Nottingham has a special connection with
TNT or more precisely a suburb of
Nottingham called chill well because
during the First World War
chill well had the main depot the main
factory where they filled the shells
that were taken to the Western Front for
all the guns TNT is bright yellow and
the young women who worked filling the
shells started absorbing it in their
skin and were known as the - well
Canaries because their skin was bright
yellow and there's a book was recently
published about these women working the
shell factory called the canary girls of
chill well and on the 1st of July 1918
there was an enormous explosion in the
ammonium nitrate and TNT works nobody to
this day notes quite why it happened but
you can see the whole place was wrecked
windows miles away were broken by the
shockwave from the explosion and a large
number of people probably more than 200
were killed there's still a monument to
these people who died but at the time it
was kept quite secret because it was in
the middle of the war and within a few
days production had restarted and they
started filling the shells nitro
compounds are useful because they call
cause dilation of blood vessels so
they're useful to give to people that
have high blood pressure which puts a
strain on their hearts because it
expands the blood vessels and the heart
can pump more easily in fact it's said
that people who worked in nitroglycerin
plants used to have to take samples of
nitroglycerin on holiday with them to
sniff so that their blood vessels didn't
contract too much when they were on
holiday and our famous lecturer from
Nottingham Biddy Shaw who used to
lectures on explosives most
interestingly was treated for many years
with nitroglycerin and it just seems
quite amusing to me that an explosives
specialist had his life prolonged by
nitroglycerin treatment